uh let's do this let's check out this
hit piece by nicole arbour
bad first impressions so yeah you're
gonna
right now you're gonna walk away but
yeah but i agree that's how i feel
it's challenging you guys probably know
i'm not like feminism because i think it
went too far
one way but every once in a while
something comes along and reminds you
why we need
girl power badly yesterday i went on a
comedy podcast
you know chop it up i already
this is gonna be a hard one the
inflection
everything
i hate this
already i
hate this already
i'm gonna really guys i'm gonna try to
get through this without yelling
some [ __ ] makes people laugh promote the
things nice microphone
you [ __ ] youtube and how long have
you been doing this i can hear
the traffic get an apartment get a
studio apartment in los
angeles with better acoustics get
something that has
carpeting you [ __ ] untalented
i don't want to hear the city bus which
you probably take to go to your little
open mics by the way
i don't want to hear the city bus
rolling past
your [ __ ] your [ __ ] studio
efficiency in el cerrito
wherever the [ __ ] you live and lie and
tell people you live in los
angeles we're
25 seconds and we're gonna
we're 25 seconds in i don't know if i'm
going to be able to do this tonight
but this was a little bit different to
save you an hour and a half of your time
that you're never gonna get back
here's kind of how it went she's making
me so uncomfortable i'm getting
hard um this loser owns a comedy
festival and a podcast network
all right that sounds kind of cool to me
ew i can't help the fact that we're
probably gonna hook up one day never
gonna happen
and by the way what louie's doing right
now this is why i like louis jay gomez
what louis jay gomez is doing right now
is exactly the only way in my life i've
ever been able to pick up [ __ ]
like i think in my crush and puss days
in my 20s
the only time i've ever been able to
pull like girls don't look at me and go
[Music]
like they don't do that no woman has
ever looked at a room full of people at
a party and went
yeah that guy you know what i mean like
i've gotten more chicks being like louis
j
gomez being combative being combative
and annoying
you that he's right when he said in that
clip earlier every woman i've ever
[ __ ] or hooked up with
it started like this it's they hated me
and that's
i'm telling you dude he's not doing
anything sleazy it's just true like
be combative pete being like be the loud
dude in the room and [ __ ] make people
laugh
even if the girl isn't attracted to you
eventually she's like i might [ __ ] him
it's all it's he's doing it right but
she's doing this whole uh sleaze ball
no he's doing exactly what i would do at
a bar back in the day
i swear to god every girl that likes me
acts like this at first with me no
it's not if i was sober and awake no i
wouldn't
okay you would at least make that one
it's probably awkward for everybody
listening
maybe no they love it they know what's
going on here they're all all my fans
right now
the fact that she's being all cold and
icy it means i like it more i think
she's just playing the game right now
nicole i'm sorry i feel like we should
start over
okay let's go the whole podcast yeah
we did have a little magic there just
now you felt a little bit at least on by
the way
by the way he's also if you if you're
not picking up on it he's doing thank
you
[ __ ] pepe le pew i was just about to
say pepe le pew
he's doing a bit this is a comedy show
right
he wants her to be rejecting him and
he's
like that's that's a funny bit like if
you have a chick on and you're just
striking out with her and you're not
giving up
it's a pepe le pew thing it's fun to
watch she's not playing along with the
bit
it felt like i'm gonna watch it
immediately
i'm embarrassed for you women in comedy
have been consistently taught that
there's some kind of barrier
to entry and that's being disrespected
talk [ __ ]
you and [ __ ] your way in there's no
way we get in there but no
let's get something straight you [ __ ]
being disrespected and being attacked
and trampled on
that has nothing to do with women okay
if you want to get into the world of
comedy
you're going to be disrespected you're
going to be mocked
you're going to be mercilessly [ __ ] on
whether you're a male
or a female that's all comics do
all comedians do is [ __ ] on each other
even when they like each other they [ __ ]
on each other it's what what they do
like
um if you go like a comedy cellar was a
notorious place where
it didn't matter who you are you could
be an open mic from queens or you could
be kevin [ __ ] heart
if you went over there and you went
around those comedians
they would [ __ ] put the boots to you
if you even moved in front of them it
was like a t-rex
in [ __ ] jurassic park the minute you
moved the wrong way they're like yeah
nice shirt stupid
what are you [ __ ] like they just
would start tearing into you
your accomplishments your life your
jokes your career
that's what it and it's every [ __ ]
day
like if you're a fat comedian and you're
ordering extra food they're going to rip
you apart
if you if you're you know what i mean
like this always if you're a fat if
you're a comedian and you strike out
with women a lot they're going to
brutalize you for that
it doesn't matter women that's why you
don't need to be doing comedy
oh i have to be disrespected and talk
down to
if you want to be a comedian then yes
yes the problem is is that women aren't
used to this
women men tend to
say [ __ ] up [ __ ] to each other all the
time and we don't mean half of it
women like to say [ __ ] up [ __ ] behind
each other's backs
and mean every word of it hey nicole i
don't know if you know this right
but the women comedians that you come
into contact with
they say far more vicious things
behind your back than any male comedian
has ever broke your balls about in
person
and the best part is nicole they mean it
you think men are bad every other woman
that does
comedy hates your [ __ ] guts i can
already tell you that
without speaking to one of them i can
tell you
those other women in comedy hate your
[ __ ] guts
as much as you secretly hate theirs
women are bred that way they're [ __ ]
wired that way
so you can't put up with guys going oh
nice car
oh nice miata how many [ __ ] be sucked
in it that's just what they
do but you get it one time uh i didn't
come to do comedy
to be disrespected by our merits i know
this doesn't just happen in comedy this
happens to women in the workplace
everywhere and i'm saying no let's play
how to spot an insecure man shall we
hey step one use sexual things to make
the woman feel weird
off balance first of all stop talking
like this
it's pretty you're not dr steve bruhl
she's talking like dr steve bruhl
somebody needs to [ __ ] wrap this
woman in a
and [ __ ] be done with it already
yes oh hey yeah that was funny that was
really makes that noise that was weird
step two
insult her if she doesn't go along with
it yes i see
crazy girl eyes look into your eyes you
get kind of lost
it's mostly intelligence you're not used
to it i'm so intelligent
i want to know i bet i
i would love to know
how many [ __ ] greasy dirty
you've of guys that ran bar shows
that were like yeah next month i'm
actually going to have a
i got a couple shows coming up could
have sean rouse coming into town
and uh a couple other guys you could
open for him but uh
you know nicole you look like every open
mic
comic that i used to [ __ ] give stage
time to
get the [ __ ] out of here you bit by the
way nicole how long you been around
cause me too started what one two years
ago let me look up nicole harbor real
quick
because all these women are rebelling
against a system that they had to take
part
in oh you were born in 85 you old
you definitely suck some oh you've been
around since
85 cmt country music television's
hottest she's been on
how we do it winnipeg comedy you [ __ ]
definitely rubbed it to get on that
winnicat winnipeg comedy festival
something i can't say death in my
opinion you did
let's look at let's look at what this
empowered woman has done in
oh she's been in film she was in a movie
called the rocker
uh a movie that had rain wilson in it oh
i don't even remember this this looks
terrible budget 15 million box office
8.8
nicole arbour start as the trashy
groupie
because that's what you are you're a
trashy
groupie uh let's see here
yeah now you definitely you're 85 you're
a 34 year old woman
first of all you should be [ __ ]
grateful
and i'm not a luigi i'm not [ __ ]
sucking up to louis j gomez because
louis j gomez
has never replied to any attempts to
contact him
we tried to get him on rotc tried to get
uh i tried to get on um
get me and royce to do like an
appearance at skankfest
i've tried everything i can to try to
reach these guys they don't like us
whatever it's fine i'm not taking it
personally but louis j gomez is not very
fond of me
and uh i'm never gonna benefit from any
sort of uh
uh overtures to the skankfest crowd
that being said lady you're 34 years old
you're 34. you've got like eight years
at best to have a kid now get it done
now because if you don't want a down
syndrome baby
you've got about three to four years to
start a family girl
but no you're gonna just waste away and
slowly get wrinkled
and slowly get angrier you're gonna be
like alyssa milano
when the guys stop acting like louis j
gomez towards you
then you're gonna get really bitter then
you're gonna really go
full feminist with it listen here
darling
you're 34 years old and you've peaked
not just sexually but you were in movies
the last
movie you were in was in 2011.
those were your glory days sweetheart
okay
just like a lot of youtubers that were
out at a certain time from 2008
to about 2011 was
[ __ ] top of the world nobody's gonna
stop nicole arbour from taking over the
world
i'm a sassy beautiful funny lady
now you're just getting older darling
you're getting old you're getting angry
you're getting that sense of like you're
watching
a renaissance happen where women in
comedy are being pushed to the moon
you're seeing women at an
all-time advantage in this industry
if you're a woman you just get you heard
the sam hyde interview that porcelain
did
any woman that had something remotely
funny a couple of years ago
adult swim would have taken it
nicole you peaked from 2008
to 2011. you're going to spend
the rest of your life looking back on
those years
and thinking god damn man it just never
got as good as when i was in the rocker
with rayne wilson
it's over for you it's over
and the problem is is that
you're you're doing a hit piece on a guy
who in six or seven years
is going to be doing skank skankfest
nine
and it's probably gonna be in some sort
of [ __ ] theater or arena at that
small arena but it'll probably be in
some kind of small
local [ __ ] soccer teams little arena
with [ __ ] vendors and there'll be a
it'll be as big as the montreal film
comedy festival but you won't be allowed
there
you're going to be a footnote you're
going to be a [ __ ]
joke in aging washed up girl
who maybe at this point is now thinking
maybe i should have done
and i will tell you this nicole i seen
you a couple years ago
you should have i can tell you this
sweetheart if you had done you'd have
more film credits
i think you're really hot hello well
[ __ ] you then you're [ __ ] ugly step
three
continue the disrespect and keep trying
to bring them down as much as you can
because when they're feeling your lowest
they'll probably give in and [ __ ] you
i'm not scared of you nicole i will [ __ ]
you up right now i'm not afraid of your
brown person either
he hates you he wants you to throw water
on you so you melt away
i'm telling you he is free he's not a
freaking elf in harry potter he is free
to leave at any time
i don't believe her i think she's got a
boyfriend i think it's a [ __ ] slave
so she wasn't oh no she really was
topless
so nicole arbour no wonder she's so
angry
she was in a movie years ago called
silent but deadly it was the last movie
she ever did
your final movie
and they got you to take your [ __ ]
top off didn't they
she was in a movie called silent but
deadly her only role
was to show her in a 2011 canadian
horror comedy film starring jason muse
did you jason muse nicole
did you see jason muse were you like oh
my god that's the guy from clerk
he'll totally get me in a [ __ ] in a
kevin smith movie
did you did you blow did you did you see
jason muse and his fake teeth recently
did you get did it hurt when you thought
back then
well you probably couldn't even get it
hard because he was on so much heroin
and he was like oh man i'm so sorry let
me work it up
i worked it up give me a couple of
minutes snoochy boochies
no if you're gonna be funny be funny but
if you're just gonna be creepy and
awkward and insulting to try and get a
rise out of me
then maybe you just don't have the chops
to hang out with comedians it's not like
it was an act just on the show
because he doubled down after
[Music]
i yes the classic i didn't want you
anyway very original sir
we all know that i could have verbally
assassinated that puerto rican jiminy
cricket looking mother
but you didn't [ __ ] but you didn't
and stop with the i could have done it
but i didn't
just like your [ __ ] underwhelming
career nicole
coulda woulda shoulda you could have
probably been in more movies
you could have probably been in on that
world's dumbest criminal show
could have done some vh1 b-roll shows
coulda
woulda shoulda you [ __ ] didn't you
didn't
you came running back to your studio
apartment with hardwood floors
and dog [ __ ] acoustics and you sat in
your little laptop
talked into your laptop mic and you
whined about it
about how men shouldn't be that way
about how
men shouldn't be that way they should be
the way i want them to be
i think we should let nicole arbor know
that louis j gomez is a real ass dude
and that
night wave and the nightway family
stands with louis j gomez